breaking tonight as we mentioned my
colleague harris faulkner sat down with
President Trump just moments ago
wrapping that interview up in Dallas we
hope to speak to her at the other side
of taking a listen to just a piece of
this let's take it the point where you
feel what the protesters those you feel
then yeah it's heartbreaking and it's
also fear that things may not change and
that there will be some who are
vulnerable people of color who the power
imbalance you talk about you know some
on some Police Department you and I are
in agreement in fact 19 percent of
police departments across the u.s. are
former military
right so I mean and you know that
touches me but when we look at how we
fix it talk to me about police reform
you call yourself the law and order
president what does that mean well we
are going to do lots of I think good
things but we also have to keep our
police and our law enforcement strong
they have to do it right they have to be
trained in a proper manner they have to
do it right again the the sad thing is
that they are very professional but when
you see an event like that with the more
than eight minutes of horror
that's a miniature Lee of horror it's a
disgrace and then people start saying
well are all police like that they don't
know maybe they don't think about it
that much it doesn't make any difference
the fact is they start saying well
police are like that police aren't like
that I mean I've seen so many incredible
things that they do but you don't see
that you know you don't put it on Fox
you don't put it on television you know
see I see that we have asked our
officers to do so much yeah they're
solving our homeless issues they're
solving domestic violence calls which
can be I mean absolutely unpredictable
when you put that much human emotion
that's right
together but at the same time we can't
live without them feeling ready the
suicide rates are up among police
officers particularly on the East Coast
in New York so we know that the issues
of really tough job are some indeed it
is when you look I saw the police
officers standing on a corner innocently
and he gets stabbed in that case by a
terrorist last week how bad was that
you're just saying what is this all
about we've seen some terrible things
happen to police officers also and you
know there's that there's that line but
most of the police officers are really
good people well joining us now from
Dallas is my colleague harris faulkner
just wrapped up that interview pretty
extensive it looked like just for the
amount of time yeah I think Harris tell
me your impressions of the questions you
ask them what the president said so you
know I think the president is quite used
to talking about the politics of the
moment Brett you know that but in this
moment there was no getting around that
the questioner looked a lot like the
protesters in the street and I made the
point of putting that out there and I
don't normally but I think it's worth
something because you can't just call
them rioters and he and I talked about
that they're peaceful protesters what do
you have to say to them one of the
things I asked him Brett was can you be
the law and order president I did ask
him what that meant by the way and he
talked about that but can you be that
and also be the consoler in chief his
answer was interesting he thinks that
the two were one in the same and that if
you get too soft then you cannot lead
and those things are important to know
about this president because we only
have one president at the
at a time and we want to know how
they're gonna deal with the moment that
I described to the president off the top
of our conversation that history may
look back on future generations rather
may look back on this historical moment
and wonder who we were and I wanted to
know is he the president that can unite
us and so that's where the conversation
went and we we talked about general
Milley and the pushback on that now
infamous photograph at Lafayette Square
and how he felt about the Secretary of
Defense also taking exception and
apologizing and regretting that photo he
said it wasn't significant to him that
they took exception and that he still
thinks it is a great moment for him in
his presidency so we talked about those
issues and we listened coming out of a
pretty high energy event here at a
megachurch in Dallas gateway very
quickly Harris do you sense and he
hasn't talked a lot about the
frustration the anger the fear in
african-american communities that
President Trump tapped into that in some
of the things he told you you know I
think what he tapped into and I can only
say this I shouldn't say I think I know
what he tapped into because he mentioned
it more than once
he watched the 8 minutes and 46 seconds
he said of George Floyd's death he he
taps into the loss and the hurt and the
pain and he understands that I think
where we were kind of pressing back and
forth in our conversation was then do
you understand how important it is for
them to hear from you in this moment
from that consoler in-chief perspective
I don't know that that is as important
to him from his perspective he thinks
that fixing the economy is how you bring
everybody together and bring them forth
he wants to restore the markings of
black wealth and that that rise that was
happening in black communities
economically and that's how he wants to
go for it it was a fascinating
conversation to kind of get in there
the president and see where he is I look
forward to seeing the whole thing and we
will hear on fox news channel harris as
always thank you